il y a eu toutes sortes de commentaires
racistes très désagréables mais je leur
ai tenu tête alors il y a une photo un
peu provocante ou je suis derrière elle
elle est noire moi je suis blanche et
mes mains sur ces seins et tout le monde
pourquoi tu as fait ça et je dis bah
pour montrer ce qui se passe dans ce
pays
on est très heureux de vous avoir sur ce
plateau Boris Becker vous êtes une
véritable légende du tennis mondial à 17
ans vous êtes le plus jeune joueur de
l'histoire a remporté le tournoi de
Wimbledon exploit que vous allez
réitérer deux fois ensuite vous gagnerez
49 trophées en simples et 15 en double
entre 1985 et 1999 on peut réellement
parler des années boum boum voilà alors
boum boum c'est le surnom qu'on vous a
donné en mémoire de votre service mais
on aurait pu aussi vous appeler boum
boum en souvenir des coups que vous avez
pris sur la tête parce que que quand on
lit le livre que vous publiez chez
Michel Lafont votre autobiographie
intitulée sans filet on s'aperçoit que
votre vie n'a pas toujours été simple
malgré ce qu'on croyait quand on vous
voyait de l'extérieur alors la première
pression que vous avez eu sur la tête
Boris Becker c'est qu'étant le plus
jeune vainqueur de Wimbledon de tous les
temps vous devez rester éternellement le
héros de la nation allemande et ça a été
très compliqué parce que tout le pays
d'un seul coup c'est découvert foutent
tennis et vous ne pouviez plus perdre à
ce moment-là exacte c'est exactement ça
et alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
quand on a déjà gagné Wimbledon à 17 ans
on ne peut que descendre et alors faut
simplement s'assurer l'année suivante de
gagner une fois de plus mais évidemment
je ne pouvais pas gagner indéfiniment et
mener le même rythme et puis même un
match sur deux je risquais toujours de
faire mais la moindre défaite serait
immense déception et je suis arrivé à un
stade ou même les chauffeurs de taxi me
demandaient mais qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi tu t'es planté alors je
dis mais comment
tu as perdu la finale c'est pas une
catastrophe c'est déjà pas mal d'être en
finale donc les attentes étaient
extrêmes mais c'était énorme c'est vrai
qu'en 1985 la victoire de Boris Becker
Wimbledon fait basculer sa ville devient
un patrimoine national et et là vous
perdez tout intimité et vous êtes vous
êtes fliqué nuit et jour par les par les
paparazzis quand vous dit dans votre
bouquin quand Boris Becker va faire pipi
c'est un scoop quoi
le risque du métier lorsqu'on a un
exerce un métier très public alors un
des effets secondaires alors évidemment
il y a tout le côté glamour gloire et
compagnie mais on perd toute intimité
toute vie privée et quelquefois c'est un
prix très cher à payer alors vous
racontez dans ce livre votre enfant dans
une petite ville bien propre de
l'Allemagne profonde vous habitez à 1 km
du cours de tennis et vous dites si le
cours de tennis avait été à 10 km
j'aurais fait du football
le club de football était à 5 km de chez
moi donc j'ai eu la chance d'être près
de du tennis alors vous racontez
effectivement la mort de votre
grand-père qui survient pendant le
tournoi de Wimbledon et on vous le dit
pas parce qu'on a peur que que vous
perdiez le tournoi vous raconter la mort
de votre père il y a une scène assez
touchante vous allez vous voyez son
corps allongé et le pantalon c'est un
petit peu retroussé sur la cheville
droite et vous voyez le nom de votre
père Becker écrit au feutre bleu vous
rabaissez le pantalon comme ça oui c'est
la première fois de votre vie finalement
où vous perdez un être
cherché
lorsqu'on touche le cadavre de l'être
cher c'est un drôle de sentiments quand
même alors vous racontez aussi vos
emmerdes avec le fisc de grosses
emmerdes avec le fils que vous allez
gagner dans votre carrière environ on a
tous ces problèmes mais vous vous avez
gagné quand même Boris 30 millions de
dollars dans votre carrière ça fait ça
fait énormément d'argent
et il vous racontez qu'il y a un jour
vous faites un match vous gagnez une
voiture de classe moyenne par minute
ce qui fait qu'à la fin du dimanche
après-midi vous avez gagné 83 voitures
effectivement ça laisse rêveur et vous
dites c'est des coups de poignard dans
le cœur des inspecteurs des impôts
ils vous en veulent à mort et commence à
essayer de vous de vous chercher et un
jour il y a une opération dans toute
l'Allemagne à la même heure à 9h du
matin il y a 150 fonctionnaires qui
perquisitionnent 50 bureaux et
appartements vous aviez toute la tout le
fiscalement sur le dos à ce moment-là
effectivement
pendant 10 ans ils n'ont pas lâché les
gars et je crois que nous sommes tous
égaux devant la loi et nous devrions
tous être jugés de la même façon mais en
tout cas dans mon cas les circonstances
étaient un peu extrêmes assez
extraordinaires parce que bon évidemment
je ne suis pas un criminel je ne fuyais
pas la justice et je paye beaucoup
d'impôts déjà en Allemagne
mais je crois que j'ai j'avais trop de
succès trop jeune il y avait trop de
d'articles sur moi dans la presse et et
c'était trop la jalousie intervient
il fallait qu'il trouve un bouc
émissaire c'était moi Boris Becker c'est
parce que vous vous étiez résident à
Monaco vous étiez et en fait vous
passiez quand même pas mal de temps en
Allemagne ce qui est interditeur
que j'ai commise effectivement ma sœur a
un appart à un f-2 à Munich au lieu
d'aller dormir à l'hôtel ce que je
pouvais payer je voulais être avec ma
famille avec ma sœur dans une petite
chambre d'habitée et donc ça c'était mon
grand crime j'ai je passais peut-être 20
nuits de l'année pendant deux ou trois
ans voilà le grand crime pour lequel
j'ai été puni vous avez été puni vous
étiez condamné à deux ans de prison avec
sursis et 300000 dollars d'amende ok
pour vous 300000 dollars c'est pas c'est
une amende c'est rien aussi une amende
alors vous racontez aussi Boris des
choses plus graves votre dépendance à
l'alcool et au somnifères vous commencez
assez tôt à l'ensemble des somnifères
des 87 voilà
le succès que j'avais rencontré à 17-18
ans
il fallait trouver une façon de
d'assumer toute cette pression qui me
commet dessus alors je m'étais tourné
vers mes parents pour savoir s'ils
connaissaient quelqu'un qui avait connu
ce genre de choses évidemment non parce
que j'étais le plus jeune j'ai demandé
autour de moi mes amis les managers il y
avait pas de réponse
je cherche des réponses que je ne
pouvais pas alors finalement j'ai essayé
de trouver une excuse pour échapper à la
pression alors j'ai parlé au médecin de
l'équipe nationale en lui disant que
j'avais des troubles du sommeil et il
m'a dit vous la prenez ces médicaments
qui sont des médicaments très courants
ils sont pas des déclinés des substances
interdites vous dormirez mieux donc
effectivement c'est ce que j'ai fait
voilà vous avez commencé en fait ce que
vous savez pas c'est que vous allez en
prendre pendant pendant des années avec
les problèmes que cela entraîne
c'est-à-dire d'abord l'accoutumance et
puis les insomnies parce que quand on
prend beaucoup de somnifères finalement
on finit par plus dormir ce qui est
assez
somnifères
c'est tout le problème des somnifères et
vous dites sur le cours je je gobelais
l'air j'avais la bouche ouverte comme ça
comme un poisson ça faisait des
problèmes de respiration les gens
comprennent pas pourquoi vous êtes comme
ça
parler de l'alcool aussi vous prenez la
première cuite de votre vie à ce
moment-là vous racontez qu'un jour vous
êtes sur la terrasse de votre maison à
Munich c'est au mois d'octobre j'ai tenu
c'est au mois d'octobre il fait super
froid à Munich au mois d'octobre et là
et là vous êtes tellement bourré que
vous demandez à votre femme de vous
abattre d'un coût de revolver quand même
j'étais à la fête de la bière
Munich
et puis j'ai passé une nuit avec André
Agassi et c'est la première fois c'est
la première fois qu'il venait à Munich
et il m'a dit bah voilà montre-moi ce
que les Allemands peuvent boire la nuit
du schnap dans ma bière alors on se rend
pas compte tout de suite et quand on
quitte la tente pour essayer respirer un
peu alors là ça vous ça vous tape dedans
alors j'ai essayé de prendre des douches
froides de l'aspirine rien à faire et
puis j'ai demandé à ma femme peut-être
plus simple qu'elle me tire dessus
qu'elle m'a batte comme ça
une carte de bons vanneur pour Laurent
qui alors à part ça Boris Becker dans
votre lit vous parlez aussi des femmes
et c'est vrai comment être sûr qu'une
femme vous aime pour vous-même quand
vous êtes tellement riche et tellement
célèbre et c'était un petit peu votre
problème parce que ça vous est arrivé à
17 ans donc c'est c'est une époque on a
encore très naïf finalement
est-ce que les femmes sont attirées par
l'homme ou par la star c'est c'est la
grande question on parlait de votre
femme Barbara qui est vraiment la femme
de votre vie
il y a eu un scandale en Allemagne quand
vous l'avez épousé parce que elle est
noire et c'est les Allemands étaient
complètement désolé de voir que leur
idole de voir que leur patrimoine
national épouser une femme noire
quelques problèmes que j'ai rencontrés
en Allemagne parce que je ne faisais pas
ce que l'on attendait de moi en tant que
je n'ai rien blond aux yeux bleus alors
ils auraient voulu que je me marie à
Stéphy graff mais ça s'est passé comme
ça alors ils étaient très étonnés de
voir que mes préférences étaient
ailleurs et que il y a eu toutes sortes
de commentaires racistes très
désagréables mais je leur ai tenu tête
alors il y a une photo un peu provocante
où je suis derrière elle elle est noire
moi je suis blanc j'ai mes mains sur ses
seins et tout le monde pourquoi tu étais
ça et je dis bah pour montrer ce qui se
passe dans ce pays
une bonne bière
quand vous avez fait votre une de ce
terme avec effectivement vos mains sur
les seins de Barbara c'est une immense
provocation en Allemagne votre mère vous
a dit est-ce que tu trouves que c'est
bien utile de faire ça
moi j'adore
l'autre soir on était à une fête
ensemble et tout le monde était en Costa
cravate pas moi et elle m'a dit à mon
fils là tu m'as déçu encore une fois
mais c'est mon style
je peux pas la changer elle non plus en
tous les cas l'échec de votre couple
avec Barbara
l'échec de votre attendez c'est quel
genre justement
en tous les cas Boris l'échec de votre
couple avec Barbara donnera raison comme
l'a écrit un tabloïd anglais au nazis et
beaucoup de journaux allemands ont écrit
à ce moment-là voyez bien que c'est pas
possible on peut pas épouser quelqu'un
qui est pas de la même couleur etc donc
ça alimentait finalement le racisme
ouais
toute une fascination après le divorce
justement parce que on a critiqué nous a
critiqué pendant 10 ans et puis
effectivement au bout de 10 ans avec cet
échec les gens nous ont montré du doigt
mais bien souvent évidemment quand ça
marche pas on sait pas
bien et alors là vous racontez votre
aventure avec Angela évidemment on peut
dire que c'est le clou du livre parce
que c'est une histoire absolument
incroyable un soir vous êtes à Londres
dans un club qui s'appelle le Nobu et
vous croisez le regard d'une femme qui
vous regarde deux secondes de trop c'est
juste les deux secondes qui veulent dire
ok il y a pas de problème si tu es
d'accord je suis d'accord elle vous
cherche un peu et puis elle quitte la
table où elle est avec des amis en
direction des toilettes vous la
rejoignez
vous la sautez
et alors une fois que la chose est faite
dans les dans les toilettes elle elle
retourne avec ses amis et Boris rentre à
l'hôtel dans un taxi va se coucher il
pense plus et un jour et là c'est
terrible un jour il reçoit un fax cher
Monsieur Baker nous nous sommes vus au
nobout le résultat de notre rencontre on
est déjà au 8ème mois voici mon numéro
de téléphone
la dernière chose à laquelle on pense
c'était ça ce jour-là évidemment c'était
mon dernier jour en tant que tennisman
et j'avais peut-être vu une bière de
trop je fêtais les adieux ce soir là
j'étais encore en vie et tout allait
bien
alors
j'en avais un peu marre et j'ai dit bon
voilà cette soirée sera la mienne je la
passe en compagnie de mes deux et puis
de fil en aiguille je rencontre cette
fille
on a fait la faire ensemble et puis au
bout du compte j'ai une très belle fille
maintenant voilà effectivement sur le
moment vous dites le seul se dérobe sous
mes pieds c'est sûr que quand vous
recevez ce fax vous dites c'est un
cauchemar épouvantable on a passé une
minute deux minutes dans les toilettes
d'un bar à Londres on se retrouve avec
une femme enceinte c'est vrai que c'est
bon c'est terrible et puis
c'est un peu plus que deux minutes à peu
près
voilà dans un tu vois le romantisme ça
te passe au-dessus hein c'est marrant là
vous avez été très bien effectivement
c'est que bon la fille était prête à
vous faire chanter si vous ne
n'acceptiez pas de de reconnaître
l'enfant et vous vous êtes dit
finalement Dieu est content quand il y a
des enfants sur la terre et je vais
accepter cet enfant et je trouve que
vous avez une réaction formidable
c'était peut-être pas une erreur c'est
peut-être la meilleure chose qui me soit
arrivé elle a 4 ans maintenant vous
l'avez accepté comme quelque chose
d'inévitable avec beaucoup de fatalisme
finalement
je me suis dit c'est vraiment ma fille
on va faire un test d'ADN et si c'est
effectivement mon enfant et bien il faut
que j'accepte la paternité de cet enfant
et alors évidemment au début c'était un
petit peu difficile parce que je n'avais
pas de relation avec ni cette femme ni
ma fille et pendant un an c'est à peine
vu parce qu'il y avait des avocats qui
voulaient plus de sous enfin il y avait
tout le tout le problème habituel mais
au bout de deux ans maintenant depuis
deux ans tout va bien elle est à Londres
j'y vais réguler régulièrement j'ai
commencé à bonne relation avec ma fille
c'est pas dans 5 10 ans ou on en rira
peut-être que ce sera la plus belle
chose qui serait arrivée mais
actuellement au début évidemment c'est
un cauchemar alors aujourd'hui vous avez
de bonnes relations avec la mère en
revanche j'avais divorcé de votre femme
de Barbara dans un divorce qu'on
pourrait qualifier Boris Becker de
divorce la Dallas puisque votre femme a
choisi une juridiction américaine et
vous êtes fait vous êtes cet axé
en tout cas elle a essayé sur internet
en Amérique parce que effectivement
dans les tribunaux mais heureusement
j'avais quand même un certain nombre de
réponses à ces questions nous avons
réglé l'affaire en Allemagne sous le
droit allemand serait pu me coûter très
cher c'était pas bon marché mais enfin
nous avions un accord prénuptial et je
tiens encore debout bien
c'est que vous dites que aujourd'hui
vous avez plus d'illusions que vous avez
perdu votre naïveté cette fameuse
naïveté que vous aviez à Wimbledon lors
de votre première victoire vous dites je
ne crois plus à la bonté de l'homme on
vit seul on meurt seul et vous dites
finalement toutes ces histoires ont
réveillé mon instinct de tueur alors à
la fois vous avez raison c'est vrai que
dans le monde dans lequel on vit il faut
savoir se défendre mais en même temps
est-ce que vous avez vraiment perdu
toute cette toute cette fraîcheur toute
cette confiance dans l'homme que vous
aviez avant c'est vrai que peut-être que
je vivais dans un rêve je suis des ma
carrière je ne te nais pas vraiment axé
sur ce que je voulais faire mais j'ai
retrouvé ma force
j'ai
une motivation pour me lever le matin et
c'est ça que j'ai je n'ai que personne
mais je n'ai pas d'inston je l'ai tué
personne à l'avenir non plus mais je
suis redevenu moi-même
et c'est quelqu'un me fait du mal ou du
mal à ma famille et bien je pourrais
réagir mais dis-moi vous avez quand même
encore un petit peu confiance dans dans
l'être humain quand même vous êtes pas
complètement déçu qu'on le force
on en parlerai pas mais j'aime encore la
vie
[Applaudissements]
c'est publié chez Michel Laforêt
monsieur et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu